Speaker 1: . It's my pleasure to welcome to
the program today, Joseph Westfall, who's
a senior fellow at the Wharton Leadership
Program at the University of Pennsylvania,
also a former U.S. ambassador to Saudi Arabia.
I really appreciate your time today.
Speaker 5: Yeah, David, glad to be with you.
By the way, I'm a professor at the Lawter
Institute at Wharton.
Speaker 1: OK, an important, important detail
Speaker 5: to get credit for that.
Speaker 1: So when it comes to you know, we've
talked for a long time about the U.S. relationship
with Saudi Arabia.
And I think that there is sometimes a simple
understanding, which is there's there's a
goal for shared stability in the region, often
in connection with with oil prices and the
oil industry.
Is it quite that simple or how would you explain
the history of the relationship?
Speaker 5: No, I think it's it's a lot more
complicated than that.
And, you know, the the one thing you have
to remember about Saudi Arabia is that U.S.
public opinion, that is the average American
in Gallup polls after Gallup polls from the
nineteen thirties to today to the latest polls
see Saudi Arabia in.
Unfavorable terms, a majority of Americans
think of Saudi Arabia in unfavorable ways,
yes, in that regard, back to the attitude
that members of Congress then have to have
because they get pressure from constituents.
Some of that is because there's no knowledge
that Saudi Arabia was closed until recently
to the world for Americans having traveled
there, they haven't seen the country they
haven't visited, although many Saudis have
come to the United States to study and to
work here.
So I think that that that lack of knowledge
and that unfavorable rating play a big role.
The other thing is, of course, that it is
the birthplace of Islam.
So you cannot ignore a country that, you know,
hosts millions of people every year for religious
services, and it has the kind of influence
that they have around the world and have had
for a long time, in addition to the fact that
the region will not just for oil, but for
trade and for also for big nation, powerful
nations, China, Russia and others has become
a very important region where we're all competing.
Speaker 1: Over the last I don't know how
many years I mean, we can we can talk about
the last five years, but it's really sort
of been been seeded earlier than that.
There has been much made publicly of what
seems to be a kind of liberalization in some
sense in Saudi Arabia, arguably, at least
to some degree, because of the direction that
Mohammed bin Salman wants to see the country
go.
But at the same time, while publicly we're
hearing about women can now drive and some
of these other things we know about, you know,
the sequestering of dozens of officials in
a hotel in order to interrogate and in some
time sometimes make threats and even much,
much worse.
So as from a diplomatic perspective, when
one thing is happening publicly and yet very
different things are happening privately,
what are the conversations like between American
diplomats and the leaders of the country?
Do they do they talk about what's happening
behind the scenes as much as they talk about
what's happening publicly?
Speaker 5: Well, it depends on which diplomat
you're talking about.
OK?
And it's really, really good question, because
diplomacy really changed dramatically after
the Obama administration.
So when when I left in twenty seventeen in
January, at the end of the Obama administration,
none of the things you pointed out had happened.
Hmm.
Mohammed bin Nayef was still the crown prince.
I had excellent meetings with him, the king
and Mohammed bin Salman upon leaving.
We had had a great relationship.
We worked on everything from their economic
transformation plan, which members had put
forth.
We worked on security issues with Mohammed
bin Nayef.
We had a great relationship, extensive relationship,
trying to deal with all the regional issues
in Syria, Iraq and, of course, Yemen.
We were fully, fully engaged as an embassy
in almost every aspect of the relationship
or every aspect of their economy, education,
energy, you name it, transportation, et cetera.
We were involved when I left at twenty seventeen.
President Trump did not appoint an ambassador
for two years, right?
And so the only diplomacy that was going on
was between Pompilio.
Secretary Pompeo, who would occasionally travel
there, and Kushnir.
So so there wasn't the embassy was not empowered
to work any of these issues and didn't have
access, and of course, after I left about
a month or two after I left, MBBS was able
to get his father to Kapos.
NBN will have a bit naive, right, as crown
prince and he was named the crown prince.
And then all the things that you mentioned
started to happen.
When so I think to ask you a question briefly,
let me give you a chance to have some more
diplomacy is critical, but you've got to be
engaged holistically.
Speaker 1: Now, when you were there, certainly
you were aware and there was this history
of the public executions and so on and so
forth.
Does that get swept under the rug during diplomatic
conversations about, for example, Yemen, or
is that present in the room?
Speaker 5: It's it's it did not get swept
under by us from the president, from President
Obama to the secretary of State Kerry to myself.
And I'll just use myself as an example of
some ambassadors in some countries, Germany,
Switzerland, Sweden and others would publicly
criticize and publicly.
You know, be very negative about some of these
practices early on when I first got I chose
a different method.
I chose the idea that we needed to to.
Help them make the right decisions, but not
going public with them in order to have access
and confidence from them in us that we weren't
going to.
So I had the conversations with the king,
with the crown prince, with the deputy crown
prince, about lashings, about beheadings,
about security, executions, public executions,
about the role of the Mutawa, the religious
police.
Who are increasingly becoming a real, real
problem for them and especially for everybody
else, and I was afraid that they were going
to start perhaps at some point attacking our
foreign diplomats.
So I was very straight with them that we weren't
going to tolerate any of this stuff.
It had to change and it had to change because
our relationship was so important.
Speaker 1: Now, how do they react, I mean,
do they do they write it off as well, you
know, that we just do things differently here
than you do in the United States?
Or do they are they aware of how those practices
are seen around the world?
Speaker 5: Yes, yes, absolutely.
They do, especially namby pamby and B.S. is
was then very keen on knowing what the foreign
press was saying about Saudi Arabia, about
him, about their practices.
So they were very well aware of that and very
well aware that that our ability to support
his plans for the economy, for transformation,
for modernizing the country depended on eliminating
those those ancient practices that that he
didn't agree with.
Right.
And we're tolerated because it was still a
very conservative element within Saudi Arabia.
People who, you know, I don't know if they
demanded that, but they expected that.
So when I went to talk to them about it, they
got it and they took action and they eliminated
all those things.
But I went back to the to the to their precincts.
The the lashings were terminated.
And the president was saying the same thing
in meetings with the king whenever we come.
He did four trips to Saudi Arabia.
I was president, three of them.
One was before I became a guest.
Speaker 1: Now, for much of what I've read,
it's unclear.
Well, I'll put it a different way from what
I've read.
It's not clear to me whether the reasons that
Mohammed bin Salman is taking these positions
of, you know, the reforms that you talked
about in that I talked about, if it's because
this is really what he believes, or rather,
it's because they've seemed to recognize that
the oil industry may not be the best place
to be solely focused in the future.
There's this idea of diversifying the Saudi
sovereign wealth fund.
They need to be playing nice with London and
New York and so on and so forth, and that
it's really, you know, just just more of a
strategic and financial decision.
Like what makes you think that Mohammed bin
Salman really thinks these aren't good practices?
Speaker 5: Well, you know, when he would again,
when I was ambassador, he took some trips
to the United States.
Yeah, he did.
Those trips, he met with everybody.
He went to California.
He met with the tech people.
He met with Facebook people.
He met with Bloomberg.
He he met with dozens of people across the
board.
I got them.
I wanted them to do their their big when their
big investment and through their IPO IPO,
through the New York Stock Exchange, right
out of me at the New York Stock Exchange.
And and, you know, it was clear that he was
trying to build support for his economic transformation
plan.
And he wanted the United States involved.
He wanted the United States engaged.
President Obama actually met with him and
had him over at the White House for a meeting.
So things were where I thought things were
going very well.
Speaker 1: And you thought it was a genuine
desire to reform, not just a financial incentive.
Speaker 5: That was, you know, the only way
I started with him was when I first got there,
the King Salman was the crown prince.
Right.
Was Abdullah, who was also a great guy.
And I really enjoyed working with him.
But Mohammed miscued King Salman was the crown
prince.
And he's the one that I principally worked
with because he was the son of the prime minister.
And I noticed his son sitting in a couple
of meetings far off in the corner, not participating.
And so I asked for a meeting with him and
we met.
And from that first meeting where we just
got to know each other, I realized two things.
One, this this young man is someday going
to be the king of Saudi.
Hmm.
Number one.
Number two, because he's ambitious and and
he has always been interested in the political
and economic development of his country from
the time he was a young man.
How do I know that?
Because then it's a background work on him.
So I saw it is his other brothers were not
necessarily of the same thing, but he was.
And that's why his father loved him so much,
because his father was a consummate politician
and his son was like him.
And so we developed a great friendship and
the friendship was, you know, tell each other
the truth.
I will tell you exactly what I think.
I represent the president and my country and
And I expect you to be polite back if you
don't agree with me.
If you're not going to do what I ask you to
do, then just tell me and you will negotiate
further.
And that's the way we work for for the three
years I was there.
Speaker 1: In this sort of limited time, we
have left the Jamal Khashoggi murder.
I'm curious your thoughts on how the Trump
administration responded to that initially.
Donald Trump kind of saying, I don't know,
I just spoke to the king and they say they
weren't involved.
I believe them.
I don't know.
Seems seems pretty reasonable.
And then, of course, the more we learned about
it, the more we learned about how at the very
close to the very top, if not at the very
top, they seem to have known exactly what
was going on.
How do you think that was handled by the Trump
administration?
Speaker 5: I don't think it was handled well
at all.
And I think that that in some ways they should
have done to some extent with President Biden
is doing now saying, you know, we're not going
to we're not going to cut.
We don't we can't prove without a without
a without any doubt that he ordered this.
He has publicly said he didn't and that there's
a rogue operation.
But whatever we know, whatever we understand
from it, we're going to have to recalibrate
as the President Biden has put in this relationship.
And he didn't do that, you know, I mean, again,
there was no real diplomacy going on, there
was no effort to really end this war in Yemen
in an aggressive way.
There was no effort to try to tone down the
ambitions of the crown prince.
And his ambitions are some of them are personal
for his own power and influence.
But many of them are also for his country.
And we needed to be sure that that we can
offset the influence that other countries
like China would begin to have, instead, Trump
was focusing only on the sale of military
hardware.
Yes.
And.
And I thought that was absolutely wrong.
Speaker 1: We've been speaking with former
U.S. ambassador to Saudi Arabia, Arabia, Joseph
Westfall.
I so appreciate your time today and this will
certainly be an issue we will continue discussing.
Speaker 5: Wonderful to be with you, David.
Thank you very much.